hey what's up you guys Denny here now
there are so many reasons I'm excited to
say goodbye 2017 Oh we'll see yeah but
the main reason is there are so many
movies in 2018 to look forward to to
break down what's hot next year I had to
bring in our movie expert movies I'm so
okay I hope you be real with you guys I
have to be real with you guys there were
so many movies in 2018 that I'm looking
forward to that it was almost impossible
to whittle it down like we would be
standing here for maybe an hour or so so
I whittled it down as best as I could to
the ones that I'm most excited for but
you guys gotta let us know in the
comments cuz I'm we're gonna miss
something I'm telling you I'm telling
you right now what's first one you list
let's start with the action movies
because I am waiting for Tomb Raider
March 16th that's an action adventure
starting Alicia vikander directly based
on the 2013 video game and that was like
one of my favorite games of all time and
this is almost like a shot-for-shot
remake at least it looks that way in the
trailers video game movies are almost
always a critical failure but I am
holding oh yeah this has your name
written all over it what I'm really
excited about of course is the
all-female ocean's 8 can't wait oh my
god crime comedy that's bringing
together Rihanna Sandra Bullock a boy
checking out the way and have you heard
of them have you heard of the babies and
way way way way more and uh I want to
talk about another strong lady real
things we're gonna horror we're on
straight to Harve do it the return of
Halloween Jamie Lee Curtis as Laurie
Strode in the final film of a Halloween
franchise reportedly that will be
Laurie's final confrontation with B
Michael Myers you see that now but like
Michael Myers has 12 lives I feel like
it's like she that's her last one but
they might keep going for Jamie Lee for
Jamie Lee all right what else we got in
the comedy world let's talk about comedy
now I haven't heard a lot of buzz about
this one but in November you know we've
seen Talladega Nights we've seen Step
Brothers john c reilly and Will Ferrell
coming back together on screen for
Holmes and Watson
I can't wait seriously no you're right
they bring the fire every time they put
out a movie every time you know who else
is returning guys Super Troopers Super
Troopers April
twenty-eight for 20 I know haha got it
highly anticipated sequel to the 2002
movie about those Vermont State Troopers
so they're sure to get into some ready
shenanigans I can't wait this is my show
we do have to talk about the
family-friendly fair though what do we
got on the sling
of course okay call me a hipster but Wes
Anderson is one of my favorite
filmmakers of all time I love his work
and it's been four years since we got a
movie from him grand Budapest hotel so
he's gonna be back with Isle of Dogs
which is like a stop motion kind of in
the vein of fantastic mr. Fox which is
one of my favorite movies ever
wow what a segue segue speaking of
incredible Incredibles 2 coming in June
do we fix our The Incredibles are back
now we also have Ralph's freaks the
Internet which a lot of people think is
Pixar but it's not I wasn't as excited
for this until d23 they showed us a
scene from this and I've never laughed
harder at an animated film oh my god
there is like princess cameos Star Wars
cameos oh it's unbelievable
going back real quick to The Incredibles
- I remember they played a really really
short teaser before Coco and people went
crazy people like ballistic they were
way more excited about that than that
frozen short so people cannot wait for
that see sorry but you know what I say
every year but dropping in 2018 we can't
seven three one seven seven seven I love
it seven I'm gonna list these real fast
ready for it
Black Panther Avengers infinity war
Dipple - ant-man the wasp venom x-men
Dark Phoenix and Aquaman that's that did
you catch that that's seven of those
I've got to say Black Panther is my most
highly anticipated movie standalone
origin wise but then we've got Avengers
infinity war which is like the Olympics
of superhero movies
does put a smile on my face
[Music]
and we will find out the fate of our
superheroes in Avengers Wright affinity
war I think so alright well we'll have
to wait and see what happens there but
we also get another Star Wars film yeah
so we're like right here in last Jedi
territory but we only have to wait five
months for the next Star Wars movie
that's solo a Star Wars story the Han
Solo movie that's dropping in May the
only real bummer about that one is we
don't get another star horseman feet
until December 29 30 well that is a long
way there are literally seven other
superhero films though that keep us you
know waiting you know yeah but it's it's
Star Wars now yeah well there's so much
coming up in 2018 you guys obviously we
couldn't list them all here and I could
say the same for music and TV so we'll
be breaking down the hot list and music
and TV and 2018 but let us know in the
comments section below what movies you
guys are excited for seriously Mary
Poppins there's so many cookies I think
a Happy New Year Happy New Year